Uh um
uh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
[Music]
we
Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh  I can make more tweets
[music
] Uh,
please write the
intellectuals  Oji fast d everything easy Dean
Transformer When it's some kind of story, now it's like
town #2
8 Overthinking rockfish Please let me know
[Music]
2:00 It went up, it’s right. It’s like the information was coming.
3 Now in our country Hmm, bad news has passed, so it’s me again. When I’m wooing, no
one is me.  Even though this is written, it’s bittersweet,
it’s a
lot
of mint,
and it’s a lot of indigo. It’s kimbap tax, I take it out once a month in March, and I like it
[music]
4 things.
Mac, please pack your
bags 4 chidae jedang more this number 3 7 3 4 4
If you have a lover living with you, a less responsive cultural property 4 a If you put it next, it will be three baseballs with a miracle of hatred or dog
[
[Music] Crush [Music]
[Music]
5 8 I'm a little bit on
the shore these days, uh uh uh uh,
just this water of money besides
Let's give it wide
3 win by 3 3 3 3 2 2 Article 3 c55 detergent uh lowe
broken dissection Maldives 2
Yasada sound's me I'm completely writing murder die bee I looked at money while suffering from edema, my
family, my family, I'm in 7th place with iron core
now
fine bur  Loser floor I mean 1g I'm going to go to the attic, so come out
[Music
] Some creepy horses
and gongs are just right for you
.
Let's talk
shhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh  Ce s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s
[Applause]
ah ri say to me right now, this is the best thing to do is to share a little bit of the trip, is
n't it not low enough?
We
're close friends, but they listen to all the different notes, but it's an employee,
but it increases.
dml is expensive to drink from the business operator
told about the
junction took place at the bottom to a certain extent both clothes fight and provide registration
ah ah
free at all but
kill is kir
hi express
okee uh why did you hate that 7 uh
what would it be
[music
] uh uh uh uh
[music]
[Applause]  ]
What a cute little crocodile Who are you? It seems like you got chased out of Narsha's clothes.
Where should I throw away Russia?
D-Bass Busan is said to be a pure alternative
Also, the company is not already left, but
your existence is brought to you Day and day
[Music]
Spreading
Some proposals are said to be seen.
A line like a child or a sleeper
lodge
# Sabutir River Boras # If it's right, let's get rid of 1 # Let's go back to the old one, write that poem
Compression is a bit of a thing
Oh, international protection Yes uh
Khao Gi Whether the wife behind the dog is going to fly
All of the zombies Burgo uh what  As if going over and over and not electing, please
give me the egg noodles
Yes Park Soo-hyun 2nd time tdd,
but it’s my day
Disconnection between eggs became possible Junseo is a coincidence, how is it a
crop? 4 Take off, a single, both cheap, bold, popular, are
you misspelled by someone else? You are not an eleven?
[Music]